Every MCU project comes with at least a few
Easter eggs that nod at the comic book history
that inspired them.
From Halloween costumes to big band music,
here are the best Vision Easter eggs you're
going to find in the MCU.
Marvel Studios has a long tradition of simultaneously
poking fun at their own characters and paying
homage by giving us glimpses of those heroes
in goofier yet more comic book-accurate versions
of their costumes.
Edward Norton's Bruce Banner passes on the
purple pants Betty Ross buys him in 2008's
The Incredible Hulk, Jessica Jones is less
than thrilled at the idea of her more comics-accurate
attire in Netflix's Jessica Jones, and Luke
Cage made its hero's science experiment garb
into his '70s comic book outfit.
Heck, in 2011's Captain America: The First
Avenger, Steve Rogers wears a clownish, comics-accurate
version of his costume before getting an upgrade.
In episode 6 of WandaVision, we get a similar
treatment for Paul Bettany's Vision.
Bowing to Wanda's wishes, Vision dresses for
Halloween as a Mexican wrestler, although
it might be more accurate to say that he's
dressed as a comics accurate Vision.
In fact, almost the whole family rocks their
comics-accurate looks
While comics fans might recognize the outfits
right away, it's a little less obvious to
the characters on WandaVision.
The false Pietro makes a number of guesses
at what Vision is supposed to be:
"Sweet costume, broham in law.
Lemme guess: A traffic light.
Half-shucked corn.
A booger!"
One of the more interesting Vision Easter
eggs we've seen comes in "Don't Touch That
Dial," the second episode of WandaVision.
Wanda is in her living room when she hears
something crash outside.
In her front yard, she finds what appears
to be a remote control helicopter in the bushes.
Later, in the fourth episode, we learn this
is actually a S.W.O.R.D.
drone transformed by the Hex.
The helicopter is one of the first things
in color we see in WandaVision's black-and-white
world.
It's red and gold with some metallic silver
mixed in — similar to the color scheme of
Tony Stark's Iron Man armor.
The number 57 is on its side, and the S.W.O.R.D.
symbol is painted on the front.
How is this a Vision Easter egg?
Well, the most obvious sign is the number
57 on the side of the helicopter, which matches
the number for the comic in which Vision premieres
— 1968's Avengers #57.
It's also probably not a mistake that the
sitcom most heavily referenced in WandaVision's
second episode is Bewitched, which premiered
in 1964 and was still going strong in 1968,
when Vision's first appearance showed up on
comic book spinners.
Plus, the Iron Man colors reference Tony Stark
— one of Vision's creators.
It also arrives with what sounds like an accidental
crash, and much of the rest of the episode
involves Vision malfunctioning after swallowing
a piece of chewing gum.
We first meet Vision in 2015's Avengers: Age
of Ultron.
But in a sense, we kind of met him four years
earlier in Captain America: The First Avenger.
Before Steve Rogers goes through the experiment
that makes him a super soldier, he visits
the World's Fair where — among other things
— he sees what appears to be an inert man
in a red costume kept in a transparent tube.
Above the man is a sign that reads, "Phineas
Horton Presents the Synthetic Man."
This is Jim Hammond, the original Human Torch.
Long before the introduction of the Fantastic
Four, Marvel Comics had an earlier version
of the Human Torch who was an android created
by Dr. Phineas Horton.
In fact, it's a battle between the original
Human Torch and the Sub-Mariner that creates
the concept of the Marvel Universe.
When they meet and fight in 1940's Marvel
Mystery Comics #8, it's the first time two
of Marvel's heroes are shown to occupy the
same narrative.
In 1975's Avengers #135, the Vision discovers
that Ultron created him using the brainwave
patterns of the hero Wonder Man and the body
of Jim Hammond.
In other words, what on the surface seems
like just a Human Torch Easter egg in The
First Avenger is also a Vision Easter egg.
In fact, before the premiere of WandaVision,
some fans were theorizing this might be the
key to how Vision would be resurrected.
As soon as fans started catching glimpses
of images from WandaVision, it was obvious
that the miniseries was taking part of its
inspiration from a few different comics in
Vision's long history.
The two most obvious inspirations are 1982
and 1985's The Vision and Scarlet Witch, two
miniseries that see the odd couple move to
the suburbs of New Jersey to start a life
together.
Another obvious inspiration for WandaVision
is 2016's Vision series, which sees the eponymous
synthezoid building himself an entire family
of synthetics, all with names — like his
own — beginning with "V." There's his wife,
Virginia, as well as his two kids, Viv and
Vin.
With the family he builds from scratch, Vision
tries to live an idyllic existence in a quiet
suburb, but it isn't meant to be.
They even eventually have their own synthezoid
dog named Sparky, built from the brain of
a dog who accidentally electrocutes itself
while unearthing the corpse of a dead supervillain
in Vision's backyard.
Just as WandaVision's Sparky is killed in
"On a Very Special Episode...," the poor pooch
of the comic book is also killed, though by
a different character.
Paul Bettany even confirmed the connection
between the Disney+ show and the recent Vison-centric
series.
Speaking to Variety in January 2021, the actor
said the series was pitched to him as a mash-up
between two comic book series – The Vision
and the 2005 miniseries House of M.
In the mid-credits scene to episode 8, we
find Director Hayward standing triumphantly
before a reassembled Vision.
There's one major difference though — the
synthezoid is white from head to toe.
While the visual is striking, it isn't the
first time the world has seen White Vision.
During his time as Avengers chairman, Vision
secretly develops a plan to take over all
of the world's computer systems, using them
to force peace and security on the world.
After being confronted by his teammates in
1985's Avengers #254, Vision relents and soon
afterwards leaves the team.
But some people aren't happy with the synthezoid
roaming free.
In 1989's West Coast Avengers #44, Vision's
colleagues learn that he's been kidnapped
by a team made up of rogue government agents
from different countries, that his body has
been disassembled, and his memory has been
erased to ensure that he doesn't retain any
of the sensitive information he had access
to in the 1985 Avengers story.
Hank Pym is able to reassemble Vision in the
following issue, but he's nothing like the
Avenger his teammates remember.
Because of extensive damage to his circulatory
system, his skin is bone white.
More importantly, he's lost all sense of emotion
and humanity.
The White Vision of WandaVision isn't the
only callback to the time when the synthezoid
becomes a lot less colorful in the comics.
Towards the end of Avengers: Infinity War,
Thanos completes his quest by ripping the
Mind Stone from Vision's head, killing the
Avenger.
As soon as he does, all the color drains from
Vision's body, turning him gray.
While, obviously, gray and white aren't the
same, in both cases, we get all other color
leaving the synthezoid's form.
Along with being a White Vision Easter egg,
this was one of many references in Infinity
War to one of the comics that most heavily
influenced the film — the 1991 miniseries
Infinity Gauntlet.
When the small army of superheroes assault
Thanos in Infinity Gauntlet #4, Vision is
among them, and it's the emotionless White
Vision who Thanos kills in the battle.
Perhaps the most emotionally powerful Vision-related
Easter egg in the MCU comes in one of the
flashbacks of WandaVision's eighth episode.
Barging her way into S.W.O.R.D.
headquarters, Wanda demands her right to claim
Vision's body.
As she approaches his disassembled form and
tries to get some sense of his presence with
her powers, Wanda says
"I can't feel you."
This is a callback to the first of Vision's
two deaths at the end of Avengers: Infinity
War.
With time running out and Thanos on his way,
Vision convinces Wanda to use her powers to
destroy the Mind Stone in order to keep it
out of Thanos' grasp, but there's no way to
do this without also killing Vision.
As Wanda begins the process, Vision tries
to comfort her.
"You could never hurt me.
I just feel you."
Sadly, these turn out to be some of Vision's
last words to Wanda.
While Thanos turns back time in order to restore
the Mind Stone, it's only to rip the Stone
from the synthezoid's head and kill him a
second time.
As soon as Vision came to life in Avengers:
Age of Ultron, comic book fans were wondering
about whether or not they'd see a big screen
adaptation of Wanda and Vision's romantic
relationship.
It wouldn't be until the following year's
Captain America: Civil War that we got to
see any kind of real romance developing between
the pair, but Age of Ultron gave us an enticing
hint at more to come.
Having left her post to destroy Ultron toward
the end of the film, Wanda misses her chance
to board the Helicarrier and is still on the
airborne chunk of Sokovia when it hurtles
toward Earth.
Luckily, Vision flies through the debris to
rescue her.
The visual of the synthezoid grabbing Wanda
and carrying her away had to give plenty of
fans chills.
It's particularly meaningful when you realize
there's a good chance Vision already has some
semblance of attraction toward her.
In order to have any idea where she is among
all the rubble and flying debris, he must've
been keeping tabs on her.
And why would he be doing that unless there's
something there that catches his eye?
In a list of Vision Easter eggs, it would
be criminal to forget the faux TV ads featured
in WandaVision, and the one that most heavily
references the synthezoid is the very first
of the commercials we see in the miniseries.
In episode 1, the story of WandaVision's black-and-white
world is interrupted by a commercial for the
Toast Mate 2000, made by Stark Industries.
Granted, Vision is definitely not the only
character being referenced here.
When the ad's housewife starts the Toast Mate,
we hear a sound identical to the noise that
Iron Man's repulsors make in the films.
Plus, the matching pieces of toast are one
of the episode's many references to the twins
who will soon arrive — Billy and Tommy.
But Vision is the character who brings them
all together.
Like the toaster, he's part machine.
He's Wanda's "mate," and, like the Toast Mate
2000, one of his creators was a Stark.
One Easter egg in Avengers: Age of Ultron
doesn't reference the synthezoid directly,
but instead, it's a little nod to one of his
real-world creators.
When the Avengers clash with the combined
forces of Ultron and the Maximoff twins, Wanda
uses her telepathic powers to force the heroes
into a nightmare world.
In the case of Captain America, the super
soldier finds himself sent back to a World
War II era dance hall, where we get flashes
of a celebration.
It's tough to spot, but the band keeping everything
hopping is named after a Marvel Comics veteran.
On the bass drum is the name "the Roy Thomas
Players."
Among other things, Roy Thomas was the Marvel
Comics editor-in-chief after Stan Lee, and
he's one of the two people, along with the
late artist John Buscema, responsible for
creating both Vision and Ultron.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
comic book Easter eggs are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.